we're asked to solve the quadratic
equation negative 3x squared plus 10x
minus 3 is equal to 0 and it's already
written in standard form and there's
many ways to solve this but in
particular i'll solve it using the
quadratic formula so let me just rewrite
it we have negative 3x squared
plus 10x
minus 3 is equal to 0. and actually
solve it twice using the quadratic
formula to show you that as long as we
manipulated this in a valid way the
quadratic formula will give us the exact
same roots or the exact same solutions
to this equation so in this form right
over here what are our abcs let's just
remind ourselves what the quadratic
formula even is actually that's a good
place to start the quadratic formula
tells us that if we have a quadratic
equation in the form ax squared plus bx
plus c is equal to zero so in standard
form then the roots of this are x are
equal to
negative b plus or minus the square root
of
b squared minus four ac all of that over
2a
all of that over 2a and this is derived
from completing the square in a general
way so it's no magic here and i've
derived it in other videos but this is
the quadratic formula this is actually
giving you two solutions because you
have the plot the positive square root
here and the negative square root so
let's apply it here in the case where in
this case a is equal to negative three
a is equal to negative three b is equal
to ten
b is equal to 10 and c is equal to
negative 3 c is equal to negative 3. so
applying the quadratic formula right
here we get our solutions to be x is
equal to negative b
b is 10. so negative b is 10 negative 10
plus or minus the square root of
b squared b is 10 so b squared is 100
minus 4
times a times c so minus 4 times
negative 3 times negative 3 let me just
write it down minus 4 times negative 3
times negative 3. all of that's under
the radical sign and then all of that is
over 2a so 2 times a is negative 6. so
this is going to be equal to negative 10
plus or minus the square root
of 100
minus
3 times negative 3 times negative 3 is
positive 9. positive 9 times 4 is
positive 36 we have a minus sign out
here so minus 36
all of that over negative 6
this is equal to 100 minus 36 is 64. so
negative 10 plus or minus the square
root of 64.
all of that over negative 6.
the principal square root of 64 is 8 but
we're taking the positive and negative
square root so this is negative 10
plus or minus 8
over negative 6.
so if we take the positive version we
say x could be equal to negative 10 plus
8
is negative 2 over negative 6. so that
was taking the plus version that's this
right over here and negative 2 over
negative 6 is equal to 1 3. if we take
the negative square root negative 10
minus 8. so let's take negative 10 minus
8 that would be x is equal to
negative 10 minus 8 is negative 18
and that's going to be over negative 6
over negative 6. negative 18 divided by
negative 6 is positive 3. so the two
roots for this quadratic equation are
positive 1 3 and positive 3. and i want
to show you that we'll get the same
answer even if we manipulate this some
people might not like the fact that our
first coefficient here is a negative 3
maybe they want a positive 3. so to get
rid of that negative 3 they can multiply
both sides of this equation times
negative 1.
and then if you did that you would get
3x squared
minus 10x
plus 3 is equal to 0 times negative 1
which is still equal to 0. so in this
case a is equal to 3
b is equal to negative 10 and c is equal
to 3 again and we can apply the
quadratic formula we get x is equal to
negative b b is negative 10. so negative
negative 10 is positive 10 plus or minus
the square root of b squared which is
negative 10 squared which is 100 minus 4
times a times c a times c is 9 times 4
is 36 so minus 36
all of that over 2 times a all of that
over 6. so this is equal to 10
plus or minus the square root of
or really that's just going to be eight
all of that over six if we add eight
here we get ten plus eight is eighteen
over six we get x could be equal to
three or if we take the if we take the
negative square root of the negative 8
here 10 minus 8 is 2 2 over 6 is
1 3. so once again you get the exact
same solutions